لجعل الناس يتحدثون أولاً ، عليك البدء
الأجساد ليس لها روح تشهد على ذلك
مادلين صغيرة في باريس سان جيرمان
يعدل أولمبياد ليون البشر بيتا
بواسطة ألبرت زافي كولما وشارع تراسيرا
من أسلوب baldas إلى bild لتظهر مي نا
ليس موقع طعم بلوا ثرثارة
قدم paquita بوابة الأسود
قال العاصمة هذا الأسبوع في دمشق
فعل orquera chiba التي جلبتهم إليها
باريس سان جيرمان الكثير
اقوال ضابط سيارة دارتي تهذيب تختلف
المشتريات عن طريق اختيار ارتباط قوي في
الشاعر الذي أشار التاجر إلى
شبوة دياتارا والجوف والتبت للقيام به
لفة أن المعطف يجعل السيدة
الكذب في زيارة بيروت في
التيتانيوم سوف يراها مرة أخرى في الزائدة
الصين ومختلف المواقع
دورة الالعاب الاولمبية ولكن بورجوندي
[تصفيق]